Musik Wir müssen keinen Soundcheck machen. Ja, man sieht schon aus. Es wird immer länger der Soundcheck. Hallo? Wir haben immer die gleichen Mikrofone, immer die gleiche Ausrüstung, sind immer im gleichen Raum, die Einstellungen sind immer anders, wir klingen immer, letztes Mal war es so unfassbar leise, deine Waveform war quasi ein Strich einfach, wohingegen meine Waveform schon so ein lustiges Symbol angenommen hat. Als ich einmal gelacht habe, sah es aus wie ein Fisch. Ha ha ha, lustige Waveform-Insider. Ja, es gibt ja so diese romantische Idee, dass man den Soundbite von Wollen Sie heiraten, Jo, ich will oder Jap oder ja, passt schon oder je nachdem, was man sich für romantische Sachen überlegt, dass man den Soundbite von diesem Begriff dann als Waveform sich irgendwie auf den Ring graviert oder an die Wand hängt oder so habe ich gesehen.
Das hat unsere, die BTF mal gemacht, unsere Firma, da musste ja auch immer der Ton durch die technische Abnahme, das heisst, da wird geguckt genau, dass kein Ton der Sendung irgendwie über eine gewisse Dezibelgrenze stösst und am Anfang ist einfach, das kann man als Mensch nicht hören, aber am Anfang sendet immer die Tonabteilung so einen gewissen Ton aus, dass der Oszillograph, glaube ich, das BTF-Logo zeigt. Ach was. Das heißt, da gibt es einen Oszillographen, der zeigt genau, wo die Höhen sind, wo die Tiefen sind, und der Oszillograph zeigt das BTF-Logo. Wie kommst du von dem Thema jetzt zu irgendwas hin, was einigermassen, irgendwas mit der Lebensrealität der Zuhörer zu tun hat? Oszillograph, Oszi, Zellulose und da sind wir schon bei unserer Cancel-Gruppe. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zur 62. Folge des Pufo-Podcasts. Des Pufo-Podcasts, herzlich willkommen. Hört uns jemand da draußen überhaupt, wie wir hier alleine ... Sag mal was. Wir sagen Podcast, ihr sagt Ufo. Podcast. Podcast. Oh, hast du das? Man hört ganz in der Ferne. Die Mareike in der U-Bahn sitzt gerade und kann sich gar nicht mehr halten vor Lachen. Ufo! Ich muss immer in der U-Bahn lachen, das ist immer so unangenehm. Warum ist es unangenehm, in der U-Bahn zu lachen? Ich finde das so toll, wenn Leute schreiben, dass sie in der U-Bahn lachen mussten wegen uns. Das sind die besten Kommentare. Dass wir sie in unangenehme Situationen bringen, aus denen, manchmal hat nicht sogar einer geschrieben, dass er eine Frau kennen gelernt hat. Ja, aber dann Leute, wenn ihr euch schon so eine Geschichte ausdenkt, dann doch bitte nicht so unrealistisch und vielleicht eine Frau kennenlernt. Ich meine, wenn er irgendwie scharf, okay, aber dann gleich eine Frau zu sagen. Das war sehr lächerlich. Und die Kommentare fand ich ja bei der Scherengeschichte damals so, ja, ich habe euren Podcast gehört und lag mit meiner Freundin gerade im Bett und sowas, dann habe ich euren Podcast gehört. Nee, zum ersten Mal wollte er dir Freundin zeigen. Ja, genau, und dann wurde ich mir gedacht, ja gut, wenn du eine Freundin hast und ein Bett, dann lass es einfach, dann lass uns bitte in unserer depressiven Einsamkeit in Ruhe und schreib uns nicht so einen Scheiß. Aber wie lustig, eine Vorstellung, ich habe einen geilen Podcast, Schatz. Ich habe einen echt geilen Podcast, soll ich dir den mal zeigen? Aber wie ist die Situation, dass man sich dann ins Bett legt? Also lagen die bereits im Bett und er hat gesagt, okay, ich mache das Podcast. Konnten sie nicht einschlafen? Ich habe diesen neuen Podcast entdeckt. Hör mal, ich finde gut, die beiden Jungs. Kennst du ja, wenn du neue Musik zeigst. Du bist immer so ein bisschen aufgeregt, als wäre das dein Baby, deine Musik. Aber du hast eigentlich gar nichts zu tun, du findest es einfach nur gut und willst den Partner davon überzeugen. Aber apropos zuhören, es geht ja gerade so ein bisschen viral, dieses Video von Farrell. Von uns in New York. Irgendwo in Saudi-Arabien ist es gerade irgendwo mega gross geworden, wir haben keine Ahnung warum, es hat plötzlich zwei Millionen Klickzahlen, wir wissen nicht warum, aber es kommt ganz gut an. Er will in der Hakenkreuzbinde. Diese Farrell Masterclass, der irgendwie so eine Musikuniversität besucht hat und dann so ein paar Studenten sich angehört hat.
Ist ja gerade dieses Video viral gegangen, wo dann diese eine junge Frau da anhört und total ergriffen ist von deren Song. Könnt ihr mal googlen, Pharrell Masterclass irgendwie. Und da gibt es dann auch die Situation, wo jeder Student ihm seinen Song vorstellen darf. Dann gibt es halt die Situation, die halt einfach drei Minuten lang Pharrell einfach zuhört und der Student daneben sitztben sitzt dann einfach sich anhören und auf den ganzen Rübergucken, so halb verliebt, halb okay, du kannst mal die Karriere mit einem Fingerschnippen beenden oder anfangen und dann mal so rüber gucken. Das ist auch ein bisschen unangenehm. Ja, mega unangenehm. Und Pharrell fand es am Ende gut, aber hat dann auch während dem Song dann immer so den Kopf geschüttelt, so in Unglauben, oh mein Gott, ist das krass. Was aussah wie, oh was ein Scheiß wieder. Genau, und sie guckt dann immer so ein bisschen, wow, was ist los gerade? Und ich habe in den Kommentaren gelesen, da muss man ja immer sagen, da sind YouTube-Kommentare geil, es kann wirklich, das YouTube-Video selbst kann die ergreifendste, humanistischste, süsseste Botschaft der Welt sein. Darunter steht immer Erster, Hitler ist noch am Leben in der Argentinien, Holocaust-Lüge, du bist sofort bei Rassismus und da hat jemand geschrieben, ja, ja, ich kenne das schon, was ich gelernt habe, wenn N... so aussehen, als hätten sie gerade was total Widerliches gerochen, dann gefällt es ihnen total gut. Das war auch so eine Umachtung von jemandem. Ja, der Schwarze an sich. Das ist auch ganz seltsam. Ich find's krass, wenn Menschen halt theoretisch machen können, was sie wollen. In dem Schutze der Anonymität machen die immer scheisse. Ich habe zum Beispiel neulich gedacht, wow, du hast die mega Idee für eine App, mal wieder, das dritte Mal an dem Tag. Ich habe dann gedacht, geil, anonym chatten einfach mit Leuten, also wie Chatroulette, nur halt ohne Video und einfach cool. Vielleicht auch mit Leuten, die in andere Sprache sprechen, um andere Sprache zu, Kulturen kennenzulernen.
Damit überhaupt kein Gespräch zustande kommt.
Genau, damit man gar nicht kommunizieren kann. Mal mit dem Koreaner chatten, warum nicht? Aber auch keine Videoebene haben, also auch diese Bild, man kann gar nicht miteinander reden. Und dann gibt es ja schon, das heißt Anti-Chat, könnt ihr euch mal angucken, oder Anti-Chat, ich weiß nicht genau, welchem Dialekt ihr euch gerade am Wohlsten fühlt. Aber das ist ganz interessant, da gibt es sehr, sehr viel Inzest und halt so ganz viele furchtbare Sex-Channels, wo man sich einfach nur für romantische Abenteuer in der Anonymität erfreuen kann. Und dann gibt es dann halt aber auch so Channel, wo ich dachte, okay, so sehe ich die App-Idee eigentlich. Aber darin wurde dann halt direkt geschrieben, ja, an 11 was ein Inside-Job, I'm a Veteran, I know, so ein Scheisser. Du hast sofort den Channel Lieferheld und Kampffisch aufgemacht, bis heute immer noch null Member, leider. Ein, null, ein Member. Stefan ist immer noch alleine, selbst du bist immer gegangen. Aber es wird noch, glaube ich, ich glaube, du findest noch irgendwann... Aber nicht so schlecht fand ich die Idee eigentlich, aber ja, Menschen schaffen es auch, das zu überlaufen, irgendwie. Das ist eine gute Idee. Muss man mal sagen, wir haben heute kein Laptop vor uns, wir haben einfach, jetzt mal gedacht, das ist die totale Impro-Folge, wir haben uns nicht vorbereitet, extra nicht. Also wir haben die 14 Sekunden, die wir sonst nochmal auf Spiegel Online vorbeischauen. Wir wollten unbedingt, wir mussten uns richtig zusammenreisen, um uns nicht vorzubereiten auf diese Folge. Stefan hatte schon irgendwie, der hatte so eine Chipstüte zum Mittagessen und dann habe ich meine Chipstüte gelurrt und da war da irgendwie so ein kleines Gagbüchlein drin versteckt, wo noch so ein paar Sachen sich auf die Hand geschrieben hat. Aber ich habe gesagt, Stefan, Stefan, so geht es nicht, heute machen wir keine Vorbereitung. Wir haben gerade darüber geredet, wie wir uns das erste Mal kennengelernt haben. Das fand ich ganz spannend, weil ich glaube, viele Hörer wissen es vielleicht gar nicht. Nee, ich bin mir sicher, dass sie es nicht wissen. Es wäre sehr gruselig, wenn sie es wissen würden. Also es sei denn Frank Elzner, hört zu, der weiss es, aber alle anderen nicht. Vor allem Frank Elzner spielt eine sehr große Rolle in der Geschichte, wie wir uns kennengelernt haben. Es war ja so, dass damals Frank Elzner zu Gast war im Nebo-Magazin, ich war damals noch in der Gästebetreuung tätig und musste dann immer die Gäste betreuen. Dann kam halt Frank Elzner mit dir, weil er wollte unbedingt, er durfte einen Masterclass-Studenten mitbringen und du warst halt ein riesen Nebo-Mann-Fan und dann hat er dich mitgebracht. Und dann hatte ich die coole Aufgabe, dich rumzuführen in der Firma. Also ich musste Frank Elster begrüssen, musste ihn seaten im Gäste-Backstage und dann musste ich dich an die Hand nehmen und dich durch die Firma schleppen, was mir eben einfiel. Wie war dein erster Eindruck von der ganzen Firma und von mir? Ja, das war sehr schön. Also dich habe ich komplett ignoriert, du warst für mich nur ein Steigbügelhalter an den grossen Ruhm. Ich finde es ja auch interessant, rückblickend, wie lange wir gebraucht haben, bis wir uns einigermaßen verstanden haben. Wir haben ja auch selbst dann, als ich regelmässiger im Neo Magazin war, saßen wir immer zusammen im Autorenraum, haben aber kaum miteinander gesprochen, haben irgendwie keine, weil es war schon so ein komisches Konkurrenzverhältnis irgendwie. Ja, man war sich so ein bisschen egal, einfach. Du warst immer da, aber wie war das denn? Also du bist dann zum ersten Mal durch die grosse BTF gelaufen und dann hast du hier, wie hast du das so wahrgenommen alles?
Das war unglaublich krass.
Echt?
Das war das erste Mal nach Frank Elstner, dass ich überhaupt Leute gesehen habe, die berühmt waren und auch noch ich cool finde, also Jan Böhmermann.
Und Jan Böhmann hatte ich kurz die Hand geschüttelt, nur irgendwie, wie er sich gerade umgezogen hat.
In dem Raum, wo wir gerade sind, hat er auch immer die Modulationsbücher am Anfang geschrieben.
So bescheiden noch. Ja, in so einer kleinen Tonkabine, in der wir hier sitzen. Viel zu klein für zwei Leute. Aber die Wände sind geil gepolstert. Das heißt, man kann, was mir auch passiert, dass ich in einem Raum gegen Wände laufe, das ist hier nicht so schlimm. Einfach weich fels. Das ist sehr angenehm. Aber ich glaube, es ist tatsächlich auch gar keine so schlechte Idee, solche Isolatoren in normalen Räumen unterzubringen. Also in einem Meetingraum von uns hängt auch von der Decke an vier Ketten, also wie in so einem Folterkeller, wie so ein schwebendes Bett hängt einfach so eine Platte runter. Wie in einem Folterkeller hängt ein schwebender Schaumstoffbalken oben über der Decke. Wow, angsteinflössend, damit es nicht so schallt im Raum. Ja, das stimmt. Schallt und halt. Ich habe ja, es gibt ja diese Voice-Cancelling-Headphones, der irgendwie die Geräusche aufnimmt aus der Umgebung und dann so eine Art Antisignal erzeugt, das dann sozusagen die Schallwellen auscancelt. Und ich habe mir gedacht, warum gibt es so etwas nicht wie eine Art Box, also wie eine Musikbox, dass man das in den Raum stellt, der analysiert die Frequenz der Geräusche im Raum. Kann man wie so ein roter Knopf drauf haben und alle Geräusche des Raumes sind einfach leise. Das würde doch jeder sofort kaufen, jeder zieht doch stille Lärm vor. Vor allem das wäre im Restaurant total geil, wenn du halt dem Ding beibringst, welche Stimmen er nicht ausfiltern soll. Dann haust du halt mitten im Tisch, ist dann so ein roter Knopf, so ein Buzzer, da haust du dann drauf und dann müssen alle kurz sagen, wie sie heissen und reden, damit das Ding eine Sprachprobe bekommt. Und dann hört man an diesem Tisch von allen Leuten, die am Tisch sind, die stimmen, aber von allen im Restaurant befindlichen Leuten nicht mehr. Ja, aber vor allem ist es doch, wenn du den Ton hast, den du canceln willst, dann ist es doch relativ einfach. Also zum Beispiel, so wie ich das verstanden habe, bei Drehs dreht man ja normalerweise mit so einem Mikrofon von so einem Stiel und nimmt dann die ganzen Leute auf. Angel. Und dann, wenn irgendwie, mein Gott, ich will jetzt nicht die Fachbegriffe, ich will jetzt hier nicht name dropping. Mit so einem Stab, Stock, will ich es mal genannt. Mit so einem Stecken, mit einem Stecker, wie wir früher immer gesagt hier, das ist mein Stecker. Und da ist ja dieses kastenförmige Ding-Drama-Fasting, was auf mysteriöse Weise die Dinge sich merkt, die man gesagt hat. Genau, die Sprachmagie geht dann durch das Kabel in die Laudibox. Sprachzauberkasten, in die La-La-La-Box. Und dann werden alle Aufnahmen gemacht und dann irgendwie in der Mittagspause oder so, wenn es gerade ruhig ist oder nichts gedreht wird, dann geht der Tonmann nochmal ans Set und nimmt nur die Atmosphäre auf, alleine. Und ich dachte immer, die Idee davon ist, dass man diese Atmosphäre dann in allen anderen Tonspuren rauscancelt, damit man nur den reinen Ton hat. Also ich glaube, wenn man, ich glaube rein technisch ist es möglich, dass wenn du den Ton hast, kannst du ihn auch rauscanceln. Ich glaube, also man kann es ja auch, wenn du Rauschen filtern willst, dann markierst du die Stellen im Musikprogramm, die nur das Rauschen sind und dann merkt er sich das und filtert das raus. Das geht ja auch. Aber ich glaube, dass am Set macht man das eher, um so Szenen zu haben, wo man nur, dass man nur Geräusche hat, also wenn man sich mal Blickkontakt austauscht, dass man dann einfach mal auch eine Szene hat, wo nur, wo gar nichts ist, einfach so ein Grundton. Warum macht man das nicht zum Beispiel für Flugzeugen oder so, wo du irgendwie die Motoren hast, die ja sehr laut sind, aber immer das gleiche Geräusch sind, du kennst das Geräusch ja, also warum installierst du nicht überall Boxen und machst dann dieses Antigeräusch zu dem Geräusch der Motoren? Money, money, money, viel zu teuer. Ja, er hat gerade den Salzstreuer gemacht. Ich weiß nicht, warum das zu money, money passt gerade. Er hat meine Hand ganz doll geschüttelt. Ja. Ja. Ich weiß nicht, ob es so interessant ist für Leute, so einen Tonblabla hier zu hören, so einen technischen Superbullshit, der immer wieder hier von dir ausgesondert wird. Du bist ja auch jetzt mittlerweile, du sprichst ja auch nur noch von Filmsets und von Sound-Sachen und von Dingen, die deine, ja, wow, Bernsteinzimmer, deine Welt. Du hast die Leute verloren, du hast unsere Hörer, die interessieren sich nicht für Technikblabber. Die wollen wissen, was ist lustig, wow, ein U-Boot ist auf Jagd in Wahlbereichen und dann Zebras kommen hinzu und dann Magnete, das wollen Leute hören. Ja, ich weiß. Das ist nahbar. Das haben die Leute schon gehört. Lass uns mal einen Kommentar vorlesen von letzter Folge. Fand ich sehr gut. Wir haben ja die Hörer herausgegeben, dass wir philosophische Thesen von den Leuten hören wollen. Was denken die Leute? Genau, was denken die Leute darum, was sind eure Theorien, was haut ihr so raus? Und ich finde eine Person, die es wirklich gut verstanden hat, auch so ein bisschen den Duktus unserer Sendung, unseren Humor. Unsere Sendung, der Hit-Montag im WDR 5 Radio. Der, der hier geschrieben hat. Und zwar Matthias, guter Freund der Sendung, schreibt uns, ich stimme nicht mit der Meinung von Florentin überein, dass Vergewaltigungen schon bei vielen beim Einstieg in die Armee Motivationsanreize sind. Erstens setzt man voraus, dass die meisten nur durch moralischen Druck der Gesellschaft nicht ständig vergewaltigen und nur ein Ventil suchen. Zweitens haben die allgemeinen Männer, haben im Allgemeinen Männer überhaupt keine Wahl, da sie zum Beispiel durch den Heerbann oder Wehrpflicht automatisch mit dem Krieg ziehen müssen. Ich glaube eher, kommt es im Krieg durch Einschneiden der Erlebnisse beziehungsweise extreme Stresssituationen zu einer Verkümmerung des moralischen Gefüges beziehungsweise der gesamten Psyche. Er führt dann noch ein Zitat an, das noch mal ein bisschen das Gesagte unterstreichen soll. Und in der Tat, ein Einzelexzess ist Song Mai keineswegs. Es gibt ähnliche Fälle und publiziert sie auch so. Eine Fünf-Mann-Patrouille der 1. Luft-Kavallerie-Division sollte im zentralvietnamesischen Hochland nach Partisanen spähen. Der Patrouillenführer hatte die Idee, ein Mädchen mitzunehmen für Spaß unterwegs. Als der Stoßtrupp abmarschierte ... Das ist eins zu eins die gute Nachgeschichte, die meine Mutter immer erzählt hat.
Ja, also bitte Spoiler nicht.
Kenner vielleicht.
Als der Stoßtrupp abmarschierte, suchten die fünf im nächsten Dorf nach einem geeigneten Begleiterin.
In einer Hütte fanden sie eine hübsche, etwa 18-jährige Vietnamesin, schlafend neben ihrer Mutter und der jüngeren Schwester.
Die Soldaten schleppten das Mädchen mit sich, einer ließ sie seinen Tornister tragen.
Kleiner Funfact nebenbei.
Nachmittags in einer halb verfallenen Hütte im Busch vergewaltigten vier der fünf das Mädchen anderthalb Stunden lang. Kannst du das bitte aufhören, so emotionslos zu lesen? Der fünfte... Beziehungsweise so super funny gerade. Kannst du mir manchmal ein bisschen moralischen Runterton.
Nein, du kannst nicht immer beim Messermann lachen. Eine Salve aus seiner M16 in den Kopf. Grinsend fragte er die Kameraden, ob eine den Goldzahn aus dem Unterkiefer des Mädchen haben wolle. So, also das sind auf jeden Fall so Storys, die wir auf jeden Fall immer gerne brauchen für den Podcast. Comedy-Podcast! Leute, wupp! U-P-D-P-U, wir haben die guten Storys, wir haben die lustigen Gags, Gags, Gags, Gags. Zeigt uns eure Freundin, während ihr euch im Bett befindet. Habt nichts zu befürchten, keine Angst. Also da hat auf jeden Fall jemand verstanden, wie es geht. Ja, irgendwer da draußen will unbedingt im Podcast gerade stattfinden. Jetzt machen wir das Fenster mal zu hier. Wir nehmen gerade auf, Frederike. Wir wollen aber die Natur noch ein bisschen hören. Diese Scheisse jetzt hier, ey. Scheisse. Nein, du musst jetzt nicht alles hier, die Roller muss ich auch noch runter machen. So schlimm ist auch nicht. Naja, wie gesagt. Also, aber ich finde seine These ganz gut und interessant. Kann man sich jetzt ein bisschen ärgern, dass ich mich da nicht mehr echauffiert habe drüber, weil das natürlich völliger Quatsch, den du da behauptet hast, aber in einem humoristischen Kontext ja auch gesagt. Oder war das schon ernst gemeint? Das war durchaus ernst gemeint. Ich finde, er hat schon recht. Also du setzt ja wirklich voraus, dass alleine, weil es in der Gesellschaft verpönt ist, so vergewaltigen, soll man nicht. Stefan, lass das das Menschen in Ruhe, dass man es deswegen nicht macht. Da hat er natürlich vollkommen recht, Herr Junge. Wie heißt er? Matthias. Gut, aber Matthias, super Beitrag. Okay, ja, schickt uns weiter eure Thesen. Eure, jemand hat eine Frage geschickt, habe ich noch im Kopf, dass er sich fragt, warum, ob die Erde immer das Gewicht behält, auch wenn Leute, auch wenn wir jetzt Satelliten ins All schicken und wir auch um Meteoriten auf die Erde kommen, wobei man sagen könnte, damals, also die Dinosaurier, die haben ja jetzt keine Satelliten, glaube ich, ins All geschickt, dass da auch schon Meteoriten auf die Erde eingeschlagen sind und das Gewicht der Erde dadurch immer zugenehmen müsste eigentlich. Aber Masse ist ja Energie, wissen wir ja. Das heisst, auf der Erde wird ja relativ viel Energie verbraucht. Also wenn du mit deinem Auto von Ort A zu Ort B fährst, dann wird Energie verbraucht. Für das Erstellen eines Satelliten wird auch Energie verbraucht. Das heisst, im Grunde wird Masse verbraucht. Ja. Benzin wird verbr verbrannt, Rohstoffe werden verbrannt, Masse wird aufgelöst zur Energie. Die Energie wird genutzt von uns dummen Menschen, die sagen wollen, oh, hier ist so kalt, hier ist so kalt, und dann die Heizung anmachen. Das heisst, wir zehren die Erde immer weiter auf. Dadurch, die Erde wird leichter, weil wir Energie verbrauchen. So leicht, dass sie steigt. Irgendw irgendwann in die Luft fliegt. Dass sie irgendwann beginnt zu steigen. Ja, einfach. Gerne geschehen, wir helfen dir gerne. Kein Problem. Also ihr könnt uns auch nicht irgendwie aus der Reserve locken mit solchen Scheissphysik-Grundkusswagen. Ey, Physik ist überhaupt kein fucking Stress für uns, Alter. Das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem. Ein Mann, nachgedacht kurz, rausgehauen, easy, ey.
Stell uns mal was zum Thema Beziehung oder so.
Ja, da haben wir keine Ahnung. Da sind wir wirklich erbärmlich untererfahren, Alter. Und in der nächsten Stunde mit Flowstar und dem Stefan.
Wir können durchaus mal Beziehungstipps geben, ich finde das gar nicht so abwegig eigentlich.
Okay, hier haben wir auch schon unseren ersten Anrufer. Wen haben wir denn in Leitung?
Hallo, ihr ist die Karolin. Ich klinge so ziemlich genauso wie der Igel und so ziemlich genauso wie eine andere Figur, die hier aufgetaucht ist. Was hast du denn für eine Beziehungsfrage? Hier im Love Radio 64, 69, entschuldigung. Also ich habe jetzt so einen Typen kennengelernt auf so einer coolen Party und wir treffen uns ab und zu. Ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt schon was Ernstes ist, aber wir haben eine tolle Zeit und wir verstehen uns gut. Und jetzt, weiss ich nicht. Ich bin schon ein bisschen überfragt an der Stelle, muss ich sagen. Was ist eine Party? 17 Fragen haben sich mir aufgetan. Was verstehst du genau in einer Party? Menschenansammlung, grösser oder kleiner fünf? Nee, es war so eine Jever-Werbung, wo wir irgendwie so ganz lässig auf so einem Hausdach ... Okay, jetzt haben sich weitere fünf Fragen aufgetan in meinem Kopf. Ich will es an der Stelle gerne unterbrechen. Was haben wir noch für einen Anruf von der Leitung? Ähm, hallo, hier ist der Bernd. Nein, tut mir leid, ich kann einfach ... Wow, im Brust. Ja, servus, grüßte noch. Ich kann einfach nicht ... Ich kann einfach die Stimme hören und ein bisschen tiefer machen. Mehr funktioniert nicht. Du hast mich mal tiefer gemacht. Du hast aber gesprochen, wie du es sonst aussprichst. Ja, hallo, hier ist Jakob. Jakob, ich begrüsse dich. Hey Jakob, äh, hallo Stefan. Ich hab noch nie bei so was angerufen, obwohl ich mir gar nicht unzuprährt, bin ich jetzt bei Fox oder bei Dreiselt gelandet? Du bist bei Love960 tatsächlich.
Love960, okay, alles klar.
Mit Stefan Thiese und Flo und dem Will. Ja, hi, was geht. Ich habe eine Frage, und zwar, ich bin jetzt seit neuerdings mit so einer coolen Frau zusammen. Und ja, die Sache ist die, ich habe mir überlegt, ab wann es denn okay ist, dass man die Frau als Bildschirmhintergrund auf seinem Handy hat, weil man ein Foto davon hat. Ich weiß nicht, wir sind jetzt seit ungefähr drei Wochen unterwegs, wir treffen uns so ein paar Mal die Woche. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, zu der ganzen Geschichte schon mal bis dato. Ja, danke. Hat sie dir ein Foto geschickt denn schon, was du als Hintergrundbild benutzen könntest?
Ich habe das mal so scherzhaft gesagt in einer Konversation, so, ich habe ja so ein doofes Hintergrundfoto irgendwie von diesem Holocaust-Mahnmal und so, das muss weg und so und dann meinte sie so, ja, ich kann dir was schicken, so, ja, toll, dann können wir ja nicht mal ein bisschen mehr Zeit miteinander verbringen, weil du bist ja nie da und immer bist du immer mit dem Hubschrauber unterwegs, seitdem du deinen Hubschrauberkurs gemacht hast. Wie läuft's denn so? Wie läuft's denn so? Ich finde es geil, sie ist irgendwie total unanstrengend und hat eine echt total geile Atmosphäre und ihre Schwester ist ganz heiß. Aber ich habe mir überlegt, wann ist es angebracht, ihr Foto als Bildschirm im Hintergrund zu machen. Wann ist es, weil es kann auch ein bisschen creepy sein, ich weiß nicht, wann hast du denn das letzte Mal? Also wie lange warst du denn... Ja gut, das würde ich jetzt nicht als Maßstab nehmen, das ist natürlich was ganz Besonderes. Ja, aber in deiner letzten Beziehung, also ja, da kann ich mich nicht mehr daran erinnern, wie lange das jetzt war. Das ist ja auch, ich glaube, das ging ja relativ zügig, ich meine, ich habe gar kein Handy an der Stelle. Aber was ist denn da ein Bildschirmintergrund auf dem Handy? Ich habe kein Handy, tatsächlich, ich habe kein Handy. Ich hatte auch noch nie ein Fotoapparat. Ich höre dich auch gar nicht mehr ganz gut. Bist du gerade im Tunnel oder so unterwegs? Zoe, wir hören dich gar nicht mehr. Bernd, wo bist du hin, Jakob? Ich weiss nicht mehr. Wie sah denn deine letzte Freundin aus? Oh, jetzt höre ich dich leider wieder. Hatte wie viele Frauen aussehen, also schön glattes Gesicht, große Manga-Augen, ähm, sehr, äh, Manga-Augen? Ja, ähm, jetzt höre ich dich wieder nicht mehr gut. Hallo, ich höre kein Tut, ehrlich, no, tut. Wie bitte? Ne, also was sagst du, nach drei Wochen, Kumpel, Bro, was sagst du? Nach drei Wochen ist es okay oder ist es creepy oder ist es eher so ein Upturn? Ist drei Wochen, lohnt die drei Wochen, was hat man? Geht man einfach Daumen hoch oder runter, blinzel einmal für ja und zweimal für nein. Ja, ist okay. Drei Wochen ist klar,
klar, kein Problem. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ich weiß nicht. Drei Wochen ist genug. Ciao,
ciao Jakob, mach's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal. Danke, Mann. Tschüss. Hey, mach's gut, Bro. Ciao.
Ist der Sketch jetzt vorbei oder machen wir noch in Hannover? Wir müssen noch mindestens
sieben Hannover machen, so steht's im Spotify-Vertrag. So steht's auf So mache ich Impro in meinem Podcast.org. Dingelingelingeling. Tropical Island. Tropical Island. Diesen Woche ist eine Menge passiert, meine Damen und Herren. Und die werden es wahrscheinlich nicht mitbekommen haben, was in der Presse so passiert ist, denn sie waren wahrscheinlich am Baggersee, haben sich schön die Sonne auf die Haut brutzeln lassen. Oder im örtlichen Freibad, schön auf der chlorverseuchten Wiese gelegen. Guck mal, die springt vom Dreier! Hey, wem soll ich noch eine Wiener mitbringen? Geil, hey, die schnorchelt, aber nicht im Becken. Und deswegen hauen wir für euch einfach nochmal die 26 besten Themen der Woche raus.
Was war so los in Kultur, Umwelt und Sport?
Stefan, was war deine erste News? Worauf hast du es abgelegt? Was hast du gesehen diese Woche?
Mega spannend, es kommen 72 neue Emojis demnächst in unsere kleinen Kastengeräte, die wir in unseren Hosen tragen.
72, darunter auch der Bacon-Smiley und der Avocado-Smiley!
Endliches Bacon da! Wupp, wupp, wupp! Endlich Avocado! Wie macht der Bacon in der Pfanne? Ja, endlich können wir auch unsere coolen Leute irgendwie mal ein schönes Bacon-Frühstück ... ne, auf welchen Emoji freust du dich am meisten?
Am meisten freue ich mich, denke ich, auf den Emoji, der den kleinen Finger rausstreckt und den Daumen rausstreckt.
Du meinst das Telefon?
Das Telefon, aber was man nach vorne macht, was man dann shakt so ein bisschen, um zu sagen, hey, ich bin ein cooler Typ, mit mir ist alles möglich, ich kann Dinge mit meinen Händen machen, die ich für unvorstellbar habe.
Aber ist das nicht so der Grüße vom Sägewerk?
Weiss ich nicht, genau. Florentin, was hast du für ein Thema rausgefunden? Ähm, diese Woche kam raus, Blowjobs sind evolutionär sinnvoll. Wupp, wupp, wer hat das rausgefunden? Der Nerdy Wissenschaftler, der endlich mal flachgelegt werden wollte, oder wer hat das rausgefunden? Ja, das sollte die Pointe am Ende des Bits sein, du hast ja schon zu früh gekommen, das steht dir gut. Was haben wir noch ausgesprochen? Was ist das für eine Rubrik gerade? Weiss ich nicht.
So eine aufgepeitschte News-Rubrik.
Nee, aber ich weiss auch nicht. So eine aufgepeitschte News-Rubrik. Was hat der Stephanister noch für geile News aus der Welt? Es ist warm geworden, hat hat hat hat hat. Die Hitze strömt uns in die Gefässe, der Schweiss läuft uns aus den Augen, wir wissen nicht genau, wow, wird es noch wärmer, Wer das Kürbis Tartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartartart Das war deine News, dass es warm ist? Welche Tipps hast du? W Bettgeklebt auf der Haut, es ist unangenehm. Unangenehm. Ich habe erstmal oben über meinem Bett direkt ein Fenster, immer auf die ganze Nacht, dass eine steife Brise, Brise durchs Zimmer weht. Dann habe ich eine sehr dünne Bettdecke, die, und jetzt kommt es, tatsächlich auch von der NASA benutzt wird. Stand auf der Bettdecke drauf. Du glaubst ja nicht im Ernst, dass deine Benjamin-Blümchen-Bettdecke auch von der NASA verwendet wird? Das ist nur das Bettlaken, das ist nur darüber, das ist nicht die Decke. Die wurde von der NASA, Adidas und anderen fragwürdigen Marken, die nicht in Verbindung stehen, konstruiert. Und die hält einen kalt, äh, die hält einen warm. Jetzt hättest du dich fast versprochen. Die hält einen warm. Jedenfalls ist es so, dass die selten zu warm ist. Kannst du mal reden, du bist hier nicht unter Eid oder so, du kannst ganz normal erzählen. Naja, die Marke, die hat schon so ein paar Wünsche geäußert, wie wir sie jetzt im Podcast darstellen. Welche Marke denn? Centerstar, glaube ich, Centerstar. Und die bringen sehr gute Bettdecken raus, an der Stelle ein grosses Lob an die Jungs von Centerstar. Die Jungs und Mädels von Centerstar. Ja, und tatsächlich hielt das echt, das ist eine sehr dünne Bettdecke und die wird wirklich von Astronauten benutzt da hier draußen. Geil, ich erinnere mich gerade noch mal, ich hatte mal ein Bett mit so einem Dachfenster, wo man dann im Bett liegen konnte und dann so auf die Sterne schauen konnte. Auf die Sternenbette schauen konnte. Und einmal lag ich nachts in meinem Bett und ich glaube, ich habe noch in meinem Leben noch nie so sehr gelacht. Und jetzt die Frage... Weil die Sterne einen Penis ergeben haben. Also ein Bullshit. Ich lag da und gucke in die Sterne und denke mir, ach Mensch, die nette Franziska, die mit mir mal vielleicht ein Eis essen gehen würde. Oder plötzlich kommt Franziskas Gesicht, die die ganze Zeit, die ich gestalkt hatte, auf dem Hausdach lag. Fast. Es war meine Katze. Meine Katze war auf dem Hausdach und guckte in den Hausdach. Aus dem Nichts einfach. Und die dachte irgendwie, ich hätte einen Herzanfall wahrscheinlich. Die dachte ich überhaupt nicht, sie ist so dumm. Aber ich habe so gelacht einfach. Es war so unfassbar. Liegt sie aus dem Nichts gekommen, wenn sie sich... So ein Katzenkopf. So von der Seite, so was ist denn hier drin? Das war echt sehr lustig. Gibt es auch viele Videos von Katzen, wo eine Frau sich beim Yoga filmt? beim Yoga machen filmt. Was für, was für mich das schon sagen?
Wie eine Frau Yoga macht.
Wurde mir rechts angeboten bei YouTube.
Und dann kam, dann sieht man halt wie eine Katze, der sich einfach vor die Kamera stellt.
Die meiste Zeit sieht man nur die Katze.
Die Kamera auch umwirft.
Die Kamera auch umwirft, genau, richtig.
Aber das ist schon krass, da muss man echt mal, das ist sowieso interessant.
Ich habe eine WG-Katze und da denke ich mir oft so, was rafft die oder was rafft die nicht?
Zum Beispiel, also was wir oft machen, die Katze und ich, ich liege in meinem Bett, nackt, aber unter der Bettdecke und dann, sag ich mal, spiele ich so ein bisschen mit der Oberfläche der Bettdecke und dann drehe die Katze komplett durch und jagt dann irgendwie, was auch immer unter der Bettdecke ist und da weiss ich immer nicht genau, rafft die Katze, dass das jetzt ich bin oder denkt die, das wäre wirklich jetzt ein anderes Wesen unter der Bettige? Ja, oder auch wenn man diese Angel mit der Maus hinten dran, mit diesem Fellknäuel hat und die dann so hin und her scheuchen kann und die jetzt immer jagt und der Schnur jagt und man das immer wegzieht, denkt die wirklich, das ist ja eine Maus oder so ein Tier oder denkt die einfach, wow, der spielt mit mir, weil Kinder sind ja auch nicht blöd. Ja, vor allem, also ich meine, ein Tier ist zwar schon ziemlich dumm, aber die haben ja schon so ein generelles Konzept des Spielens. Also auch wenn sie mit ihren Geschwistern spielen, dann beißen die ja nicht wirklich zu und kratzen nicht wirklich zu und tun nur so. Also die haben schon ein Konzept des Spielens. Und wenn die das dann fassen, was auch immer unter der Bettdecke ist, dann kratzen die da auch nicht rein und beißen und so, sondern die checken das dann glaube ich schon. Wir reden schon von deinem Penis unter der Bettdecke jetzt, oder? Nein. Habe ich die ganze Zeit gedacht, mega widerliches Bitgrad in meinem Kopf. Nein. Oh, lass es endlich enden, denke ich mir die ganze Zeit. Wann ist endlich das Thema vorbei? Ach Gott, fick dich doch aus. Nein, nee, hast schon recht. Lass uns mal einen Katzenwissenschaftler einladen. Hier ist Dr. Miao, der Katzenwissenschaftler, der sich seit 14 Stunden mit Katzen beschäftigt. Herzlich willkommen, sehr gegrüßt. Hi, herzlich willkommen. Hallo, hallo, erstmal schön willkommen. Sind Sie gut reingekommen? Ja, ins Jahr der Katze, meinen Sie? Wie bitte? Ins Jahr der Katze, meinen Sie? Ist jetzt in China, Jahr der Katze. Ach wirklich? 2016 ist das Jahr der Katze? Ja, weiß ich nicht genau. Ich habe den Wikipedia-Artikel gestern gelesen, kann sein, das ist 1938, kann auch jetzt sein. Aber es ist jedenfalls mal Jahr der Katze, ja. Wie sind Sie denn dazu gekommen, sich mit Katzen zu beschäftigen? Gestern, ich bin nicht aber auf zufälligen Wikipedia-Artikel geklickt und dann kam das plötzlich. Katze? Ja, ich fände es cooler als zum Beispiel das Militär-U-Boot 83 aus der russischen Sowjetunionszeit. Im Gegensatz zur belgischen Sowjetunion, die in den 80er Jahren Konkurrenzbrunten aufgebaut hat.
Da habe ich die Sowjetunionzeit aus Sicht der Russen, aus Sicht von Andoranern.
Ja, aber warum genau Katzen? Also was fasziniert sie so sehr daran, dass sie sich so in dieses Thema reingesteigert haben?
Ja, die Augen faszinieren, dass sie so einen Schlitz haben, der von oben nach unten geht, habe ich so noch nicht gesehen.
Ja, das ist ziemlich crazy.
Wie viele Beine haben denn Katzen? Sechs, vier, zählt der Schwanz mit als fünf. Ich lege mich fest vier. Vier ist richtig. Yes. Warum haben denn Katzen Schwanz eigentlich? Um auszugleichen, dass sie in Kurven schnell das Gewicht verlagern müssen, um die Kurve zu erwischen. Dann gleichen sie mit dem Schwanz, gleichen sie die Bewegungen aus. Genau wie das G-Paden machen oder andere Raubkatzen. Oder C-Paden. Ist es hier noch der Wissenschafts-Podcast? Wie bitte? Ist es hier noch der Wissenschafts- Nee, es ist der Kinderkanal. Wir wollen das auch so ein bisschen lustiger machen. Viele Kinder haben ja Katzen zuhause und fragen sich immer so, wie sollen wir mit Katzen umgehen. Viele Katzen haben da Probleme mit der Lautstärke, mit dem Licht. Was würden Sie denn so sagen, was sind denn so die vierhundertsechzehn Tipps, wie muss man mit einer Katze umgehen, dass man der das Leben auch nicht allzu schwer macht? Möglichst neutral. Also das Haus sollte möglichst durchschnittlich aussehen, mit dem durchschnittlichen Katzenspielzeug nicht zu viel, nicht zu wenig, sage ich immer. Wie viel ist das ungefähr, wie viel Katzenspielzeug pro Katze, also pro Bein? Also ein Katzenbaum, Kratzbaum, ein, ja, also so Entscheidungen, die man normalerweise fehlen würde. Das sind die richtigen, oft die richtigen Entscheidungen. Weit ist das Erste, woran man denkt, wenn man sagt, oh, würde ich jetzt eine Katze kaufen, dann würde ich mir ja auch, hmm, Katzenfutter zum Beispiel. Oft ist das Erste, was man denkt, das ist die richtige Entscheidung für Katzen. Kann ich kurz Werbung machen für mein Privatprojekt? Ich habe jetzt eine Band, die Tollkünen drei, wir machen Punkrock, auf Deutsch kann ich dafür, wir haben jetzt bald ein Konzert am Donnerstag und bislang hat nur die Moni zugesagt.
Ja, ich will da ganz kurz mit dem Thema Nachtsicht sprechen, weil Katzen sagt man ja auch oft nach, also geht es zumindest als Gerücht um, dass sie in der Nacht sehen können.
Ja, das weiss ich nicht genau. Wie gesagt, die Tollkwühlen drei, wir haben neue Songs im Petto jetzt, wir fangen an um 20 Uhr im Jugendfeilzeitzentrum Herne und da haben wir jetzt auch ein paar Überraschungen auf Lager, würde ich sagen. Der Tommy, Gitarrist aus einer befreundeten Band, ist jetzt zum ersten Mal, macht bei uns mit. Und wie gesagt, es ist auch der eigenen Soundmann da, der uns auch jetzt endlich mal gut klingt und das wird schon toll, glaube ich. Wir spielen 13 Songs. Haben Sie denn selber eine Katze auch?
Ich mag Katze eigentlich gar nicht so gern.
Ich habe einen Leguan.
Wie heisst der?
Bernd.
Ich warte noch auf eine Schlusspointe, damit das Bit zu Ende sein kann.
Aber Bernd war okay, von daher.
Das war Professor Doktor Miao. Das war Stefan Dietze als der Katzenprofessor und Florian Hildwell als überforderter Radiomoderator. Uh, das war ein super Skitch. Das war geht so. Wir wollen mehr davon. Nein, wir wollen weniger davon. Wir wollen patreon.com slash das Podcast und wo viel mehr spenden, um noch mehr Hörspiele zu bekommen. Das Fenster. La Vendetta. Elg. Eine Französisch-Klausur denken. Also was man teilweise für ein Schwachsinn erzählt hat. Französisch war bei mir irgendwann der Knackpunkt, ich war immer sehr schlecht in Französisch, aber ich habe immer auch schlechte Noten bekommen und das fand ich unfair. Ich dachte mir, ich bin lieber schlecht und kriege trotzdem gute Noten, das war meine Idee. Und dann dachte ich mir, das Einzige, was Version A von Version B unterscheidet, ist das Selbstbewusstsein.
Wenn du einfach irgendwann sagst, ich denke, ich kann Französisch sprechen und meldest dich und laberst einfach mit dem Französisch, was du so denkst, das richtig ist, dann denkt der Lehrer auch so, okay, cool, der beteiligt sich, ist immer immer dabei und die anderen machen das gar nicht und so und versuchen da immer Sachen auszumachen, dann kriegt er auf jeden Fall gute Noten. Motivation ist aber wirklich ein grosser Punkt. Ist, glaube ich, wirklich so.
Und einfach jeder Lehrer freut sich, wenn bei der Frage irgendwie
Wuhle, Wuhkoszumachen, dann kriegt er auf jeden Fall gute Noten. Motivation ist, glaube ich, aber wirklich ein grosser Punkt. Ist, glaube ich, wirklich so. Jeder Lehrer freut sich, wenn bei der Frage irgendwie
Wuhle, Wuhu, Kuschel, Wuh, irgendwie Leute sich melden. Jemand in dem Fake-Spanisch, dann anfängt den Schein. Warum hat er da einfach einfach ein paar Rehompe die Reckes an, so ein bisschen die Reckes an, so ein bisschen die Reckes an, so ein bisschen die Reckes an, so ein bisschen die Reckes an, so ein bisschen die Reckes an, so ein bisschen die Reckes an, so ein bisschen die Reckes an, so ein bisschen die Reckes an, so ein bisschen die Reckes an, Rauchenflony, du kannst nicht einfach ein...
Rotwein...
Wasser nimmt das Piano her, du kannst nicht einfach ein Chanson hier rauchen spielen.
Mit so einer Kapitulationsfahne, einfach so die ganzen Klischees.
Und da habe ich irgendwann auch angefangen, ich weiß noch genau... Und dann wollte ich irgendwann mal erzählen, dann gab es so Prüfungen, wo man dann so Diskussionsthemen hatte, wo man irgendwie so Sachen diskutieren sollte. Dann sollte jeder so sein Endplagiat... Ach man, ey ... Es kann auch in alle Richtungen gehen, die Geschichte. Wie ist das beim Gerichtssaal das letzte Statement? Plädoyer. Plädoyer halten. Und dann sollte ich mein Plädoyer halten und dann wollte ich ... Das ist am ersten französisch klingenden Wort der Geschichte scheitert, gerade die Geschichte über Französisch. Und dann ist mir das Wort für überall nicht eingefallen. Ich wollte es aber verwenden, weil dann habe ich mir überlegt, wie kann man das überschreiben, umschreiben. Ich habe mich auch mega in meinem Kabel verheddert. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, was los ist. Du schwitzt selbst gerade aus den Ohren. Was ist denn hier eigentlich los? Ich bin mega nervös gerade, ich weiß gar nicht warum. Aber auf jeden Fall habe ich versucht, den Begriff überall zu umschreiben und dann wollte ich sowas schreiben wie, wenn man nur aus dem Fenster schaut, ist es überall. Ja, irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, es ging um, was heisst ich, Jugendliche, die Angst vor der Zukunft haben oder so und dann ist mir überall nicht eingefallen und dann habe ich aber das Wort für Fenster ist mir auch nicht eingef Not, weil der Satz schon so weit fortgeschritten war, habe ich einfach irgendein Wort gesagt, ich weiß nicht mehr genau welches, aber auf jeden Fall heißt es Ofen. Und dann einfach, wenn man, habe ich gesagt, wenn man mal aus dem Ofen schaut, sieht man überall und das, weiss ich noch genau, wirklich alle drei. Und dann auf Elternabend, wir machen uns ein bisschen Sorgen um die Gesundheit dieres Sohnes. Wo wirklich alle drei betreuenden Lehrer mich gleichzeitig so Stirn runzeln, so, wovon zur Hölle redet der? Aber das ist auch so, weil wenn man das so relativ selbstbewusst einfach von sich gibt, so, ja mein Gott, Leute, wenn ich einfach ein bisschen auf den Ofen schaue, dann wisst ihr ja selber, dass das ein riesiges Problem ist. Das geht dann auch manchmal unter. Bei mir ist es auch so, ich konnte mit Vokabeln nicht gut merken, aber Songtexte sehr gut.
Und ich habe sehr oft einfach Songtexte bei Englisch-Klausuren zitiert. Einfach so, und die waren kontinuierlich unterstrengelt mit so einem Strich, diesem wütenden Strich und dann Ausdruck, dieses A für Ausdruck dahinter. Ach so, weil es keine Nummer gibt. Ja, weil es halt so eine lyrische Sprache ist und man einfach so einen Unfall beschreiben sollte, wie das passieren konnte. Und dann steht da einfach, ja, das ist man, die Sprache, die man benutzt, wird taub und so eine Scheisse halt, was man in irgendwelchen Songs gehört hat. I'm just a poor boy from a poor family, my name is Stefan. The Bees-a-Bob has never put aside for me, for he's a jolly good fellow, for he's a jolly good fellow, for he's a jolly good fellow, for he's... Du Du musst das nicht alles dreimal schreiben, du darfst drei schon. My love is brilliant, my love is pure, I saw an angel, oh that I'm sure. All the single ladies, all the single ladies. Gezeichnet Stefan. James Blunt, okay. Hören Sie nun eine fantastische Reizwortgeschichte von Stefan Tibi-Titze. Seine Reizwörter sind Kissenschlag. Ganz kurz, ich habe überlegt, T.J. Miller ist ja einfach cool, der konnte einfach seine coolsten, seine coolen Vornamen benutzen, weil du mich gerade Stefan Tibi-Titze genannt hast. Ja. Ich habe überlegt, meine beiden Vornamen zu benutzen und dann, hm, Tietze wie T.J. Miller, weil es einfach cool klingt, oder Louis C.K., aber es wäre bei mir SM-Tietze. Danke an der Stelle. SM. Wow, man muss auch mal sagen, wir sind dann nach New York geflogen und auf der Ticketübersicht, weil wir eine Gruppe die Tickets gebucht haben, in der Ticketübersicht stand Stefan und dann nur in Großbuchstaben Michael und dann Titze wieder normal. Einfach alle normalen Namen normal, nur bei Stefan, Stefan, Michael, Titze. Aber kann man das machen, kann man Kinder in Caps benennen, einfach nur? Ich glaube, das geht. Johann! Ja, ich glaube, das geht. Du kannst auch so Litzbeak so Nummern einbauen oder Ausrufe zeigen, einfach Ausrufe zeigen. Lisa! So eine Regieanweisung, betritt den Raum, Marie. Ja, finde ich nicht schlecht. Reizwortgeschichte. Reizwortgeschichte, hören Sie nun die fantastische Reizwortgeschichte von Stefan Dietze. Seine Reizworte lauten Kissenschlacht, Pfirsich und Burg. Es war einmal die Geschichte der Pfirsichprinzessin. Zielt das schon in der Überschrift eigentlich? Ja. Muss ich es nochmal aufgreifen? Ich glaube, es wird schwierig, die Geschichte zu erzählen, ohne die Prinzessin nochmal zu erwähnen, aber go for it. Es war einmal die Pfirsichprinzessin, sie lebte in ihrer einsamen Burg im höchsten Zimmer, das jemals jemand zu erreichen versucht hatte. Ein einsamer Ritter betrat die Burg. Warum sind alle einsam in der Welt? Weil damit sie dann noch einen Anreiz haben, nicht zusammenzukommen vielleicht. Ist das auch im Text? Steht das dann auch im Text? Ja, wütend, in Caps. Sorry. Der einsame Ritter betritt den Raum, herrte sich auf Tinder, mit der einsamen Prinzessin verabredet. Das waren beides Nutzernamen bei Knuddels, einsamer Ritter, einsamer Prinzessin. Da dachten sie, what, wir haben uns genau gleich genannt, wohnst du auch in Osnabrück? Ja, komm, ich komme einfach vorbei. Er betritt das Haus der einsamen Prinzessin und dann glaubt er nicht, was er sieht. Die einsame Prinzessin ist mit seinem besten Freund gerade mitten zu Gange. Er glaubt seinen Augen nicht. Das darf doch nicht sein. Die beiden jetzt oder was? Und die beiden waren einfach in der heftigsten Kissenschlacht, die er jemals gesehen hat. Die Federn flogen nur so um den Raum herum, landeten sogar auf dem Boden. Und dann hat er gesagt, nee, kann ich auch mitmachen? Wir haben uns einfach verabredet, warum machen wir die Kissenschlag nicht? Woraufhin sie sagte, ja, kein Problem, deshalb kannst du gerne mitmachen, das muss ich nicht so jetzt da aufregen drüber. Wohin er mitmachte und die drei, wenn sie nicht gestorben sind, dann schlagen sie noch heute mit Kissen um sich. Oder es kam vielleicht sogar zu einer Küstenschlacht. Das wäre lächerlich. Das wäre total absurd. Ich fände es so gut wie mit dem Boden, als hättest du noch so ein awkward Reizwort. Und eine Feder fiel sogar auf einen Gärtner. Den Kleiderschlein. Einfach so, was? E? Einer Boden liegenden Säbel. Sehr gut, Stefan. Die Reizwortgeschichte von Florianin Benedikt Bill. Seine Reizhörter sind Kabelsalat, Photosynthese und Chloroform. Bitte passt, wir tauchen ein. Wir sehen den Mars, also das Restaurant Mars, nicht den Planeten. Macht euch nicht lächerlich. In dem Restaurant, Zugange, Larry. Er sitzt, seine Blut wird abgedrückt von mehreren Ethernet-Kabeln, die um seinen Unterarm gewickelt wurden. Er ist in eine Pickel, hieß in eine Pickel, er hatte sich verfangen. Bei seinem Auftrag, den Spielautomaten Spielomat 4000 zu reparieren, verhättete er sich in den Kabeln des Automates. Er war sozusagen gefangen in einem Kabelsalat. Yeah, da ist das Wort!
Wie bitte?
Da ist das Wort!
Er dachte sich, Kabelsalat, das ist doch was für Vegetarier. Niemand hörte seinen schlechten Gag und trotzdem lachte das gesamte Restaurant laut auf. Gegessen wurde nur Salat. Ähm, und er dachte über Photosynthese nach und dachte sich, meine Herren, das ist echt ein krasser Scheiss, dass die nur mit ihrem grünen Kram da irgendwie so ein Zeug rumdödeln müssen. Und dann dachte er noch weiter nach über andere Sachen, wurde ihm aber schlagartig klar, dass er gar nicht mehr genau wusste, was das dritte Reizwort war. Und dann auch noch ein bisschen nachgedacht, hat sich kurz überlegt, Chloropharm.
Genau, hat sich kurz überlegt,
Chloroform. Genau, hat sich kurz überlegt, wie er das jetzt am besten machen sollte, dieses Wort einzubauen.
Und dann sagt er, mein Gott, ich müsste echt mal wieder ein bisschen in Form kommen, am besten im Schwimmbad.
Chloroform. Bitches. The end. Aber ich habe auch überlegt, wenn du mir kurz mal drei Reizwörter geben könntest, einfach mal irgendwelche drei Wörter. Facebook, Zwiebel und Nebukadnezar. Ja, wenn du einfach anfängst, die Geschichte mit Bernd saß in seinem Zimmer. Bernd dachte darüber nach, wie er eine Reizwortgeschichte mit Nebukadnezar, Facebook und Zwiebel schreibt. Er kam zu keinem gescheiten Ergebnis. Das ist dann wieder Meta-Meta. Ja, darf man das machen, so eine Meta-Shit? Steht dann aber, glaube ich, auch nicht in der Anforderung mit, hey du, herzlich willkommen zu deiner ersten Klausur, heute musst du diese drei Reizwörter einbauen. Bitte mach kein fucking Meta-Shit. Bitte lass die vierte Wall so wie sie ist, Bianca. Carina mit dem Herzchen über dem i. Geht glaube ich, das würde glaube ich funktionieren. Wie du dich einfach so sexy mit deinem Schweißverdenken einfach an der Wand regnst. Das ist ja unangenehm gerade hier drin. Bist du oft in der Sauna? Ich bin sehr oft in der Sauna. Wir haben heute echt einer Kollegin den ganzen Tag lang weiss gemacht, dass wir zusammen in die Sauna gehen, relativ häufig. Und die Kollegin hat es einfach akzeptiert. Ja, ich glaube, es ist gar nicht so schwer, Leute davon zu überzeugen, weil das auch normale Menschen einfach machen. Okay, aber in meinem Kopf war es wahnsinnig lustig die ganze Zeit, dass sie wirklich dachte, dass wir jede Woche gemeinsam in die Sauna gehen.
Wir sollten mal in die Sauna gehen zusammen.
Ja, aber mit Handtuch um den Kopf.
Ich bekomme heute ein Paket von DPD und ich will mal kurz einen Shoutout raushauen an die tollen, tollen Leute bei DPD und das tolle Engagement, was sie da wirklich an den Tag legen. Die schreiben einem vorher, wann das Paket kommt, genau die Uhrzeit, dann kann man auf einen Button klicken, wo man genau das Auto verfolgen kann, ortungsmässig, wo sieht man genau, wo das Auto ist, wann es bei dir ist, du kannst vorher auch noch angeben, genau, wo die das Paket abstellen sollen, bei welchem Wunschnachbarn, wenn du nicht da bist. Du kriegst 24 Stunden vorher eine Mail, du kriegst eine Stunde vorher eine Mail. Du kriegst viel zu viele Mails, das ist nicht die Wahrheit. Aber das ist schon sehr toll, wie die dich da heranführen, wie die dich darauf vorbereiten, dass du ein Paket bekommst. So eine Ereignis, was man nur einmal im Leben hat. Wenn man sich vorstellt, man macht einen Fallschirmsprung, man kriegt ganz viele Informationen darüber, genauso lief es bei DPD, obwohl die einfach nur ein Paket liefern. Ja, in drei Stunden. Ja, ist gut. Ich bin gespannt, was da passiert. Aber wie ist es bei dir? Also ich glaube, dass irgendwann mal die Jungs von DHL kommen bei mir und die ganze Wohnung ausräumen. Einfach die ganze Wohnung aus dem Grund, weil ich glaube, dass die meisten Sachen nicht legal mir gehören. Weil wenn DHL-Bote kommt zu dir, die was bringt, wie unterschreibst du dann? Du kannst doch nicht wirklich mit deiner Unterschrift unterschreiben, oder? Bei diesem kleinen Ding. Man hat doch jegliche Mühe aufgegeben, da seine richtige Unterschrift. Wenn die irgendwann sagen, Herr Dietze, das ist aber diese 58 Mal, die wir bei Ihnen waren das letzte Mal, ist aber nicht wirklich ihre Unterschrift.
Wir haben hier ihre Unterschrift und ihre Kreditkarte, das ist sie nicht, das gehört alles gar nicht ihnen und irgendwann räumen die einfach meine ganze Wohnung aus. Ja, vor allem auch, ich finde es auch immer super, merken, das ist so albern, dass wenn man da irgendwie mit einer Karte bezahlt und die haben keinen so ein Tippding, sondern man muss unterschreiben, dann gucken die ja auch nochmal immer so auf die Karte. Oder ich musste sogar einmal extra nochmal meine Karte rausholen und ergeben und dann guckt ihr, wo ich mir denke, wenn ich das jetzt fälschen wollte, meinst du nicht, ich habe mir kurz die Unterschrift angeguckt, die dreimal geübt und könnte die für dein unbelehrendes Auge jetzt fälschen oder was? Also was soll da der große Sicherheit sein? Ich bin relativ jung, ich hatte bis vor einem Jahr die erste Karte, die ich jemals bekommen habe von der Sparkasse, wo ich einfach in grossen Druckbuchstaben Stefan mit so einem umgedrehten N, weil ich noch nicht konnte das N, einfach ganz falsch geschrieben habe. Und dann dachte ich mir immer, oh, vor allem ja war das noch, da haben die dann angefangen die Karte anzugucken und dann, ja, unterschreiben Sie mal bitte. Und dann die Karte noch so, überprüfen das dann. Wo ich dann auch immer gestoppt habe, kurz gesagt habe, Sie werden jetzt nicht das Ergebnis vorfinden, was Sie sich wünschen. Das ist nicht meine Unterschrift, das unterschreibe ich nicht mehr. Und dann weiß ich nicht, was Sie sehen wollen, ob ich das N falsch rumm mache oder so, keine Ahnung. Ja, vor allem ist es ja sowieso interessant, dass man auch auf seinem Ausweis im Alter von 16 irgendwie seine Unterschrift festlegen muss, die dann einfach mal für ein paar Jahre gilt. Ja, gilt dann. Ich habe eine Schreibschriftunterschrift, was komisch ist, weil ich eine Schreibschrift nie benutze, ausser... Schrift. Deine Handschrift ist wirklich das lächerliche, was ich dir sagen würde. Was soll das denn jetzt für einen Angriff hier von der Seite sein? Ja, mir gefällt deine Handschrift einfach nicht. Warum, was ist deine Handschrift nicht? Ja, es stört mich einfach. Wenn du im Autorenraum einfach mal Ideen nonchalant an die Wand schreibst, einfach, dann geht bei den Kollegen aber das Augenrollen um, sag ich mal. Warum denn? Wir können das nicht leiden, wie du das schreibst. Deine Handschrift ist einfach lächerlich. Aber warum, was macht sie lächer ganzen, diese kindlichen Kringel, diese I-Punkte, die du immer ausmaltest und deine bescheuerten A's. Deine A's, die haben echt völlig einen Hau weg. Das ist echt unangenehm. Wie ist das, dass du mir so ein Rückenfels echt sagt? Nein, das ist schon ein Länkung auf meiner Seele und ich wollte es mir einfach mal aussprechen, da hat mir immer klar Schiff machen. Aber die Handschrift ist ein Tor in die Seele, also das tut mir jetzt schon sehr intim weh. Ja, heisst bestimmt, wenn er das untersuchen lässt, wow, du bist mega kreativ und so ein Bullshit. Aber die Handschrift geht jedem im Autorenraum auf den Sack. Da kannst du jeden fragen. Okay, sorry. Du drängst dich immer so auf, dass du die Übersicht machst, wo man dann schreibt Sendung 41, Sendung 42, Sendung 43. Du drst dich immer so auf, aber wir wollen nicht immer deine Schrift da sehen. Und wir müssen erst mal Sendung eins machen, also eins nach dem anderen. Und du hast die 42 vergessen. Und so schreibt man auch keine vier. Es sind, in dieser Staffel drei ist Sendung ausgefallen, ich weiss nicht, ob dir das aufgefallen ist, wir haben da eine grosse Geschichte drum gestrickt, eigentlich lag es daran, weil Florentin die Nummerierung verkackt hat. Die Nummern vergessen hat einfach. Was kam nach drei? Ich schreibe einfach sechs. Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau. Sechs. Das ist schwierig. Nee, aber du hast recht. Mit deiner Geschichte vom Anfang, wo du erklärt hast, ich wurde das in Chester von Trin. Ja, ich weiss ja nicht genau, wie du schneidest, aber ich sag einfach mal so ein paar Soundbytes. Ja, das stimmt schon, Stefan. Nee, da gebe ich dir völlig recht. Ja, du hast recht. Danke, jetzt noch drei Abmoderationen, dann haben wir es schon. So, das war das Podcast UFO für Folge 61, 62, 63, 64. Seid doch beim nächsten Mal wieder dabei, wenn es heißt, das Podcast UFO hebt ab. Sehr gut. Stefan, du bist, also, heute habe ich mal eine Seite von dir gesehen, die ich nicht kannte. Und das fand ich eigentlich ganz schön, weil Stefan ist eigentlich so der Fels in der Brandung. Weißt du, auf den kann man sich verlassen, der dicke, breite Schultern, auf die man viel bauen kann. Dicke, dicke, fette, triebische, schwitzende, aber heute kamen wir immer schön aus dem Netto. Stefan geht aus dem Netto und ab dann war ein anderer Mann. Ihm flog irgendwie ein Bündel Pollen in die Nase. Und er schnappte kurz über, schnappte auch wirklich wütend nach diesem Pollen, als wollte er es dafür bestrafen, dass es existiert. Ich hab's real, wie so ein Eichhörnchen, wenn es einen Ball sieht. Ja, oder wie so, kennst du dieses Video von diesem Husky-Welpen, der eine Limone anleckt und dann halt ist es total sauer und unangenehm und dann haut er mit seiner Pfote so auf die Limone drauf, als ob der die jetzt dafür bestrafen will, dass sie sauer ist. Ey, was ist denn das für ein Scheiß gerade? Scheißkacke, ey, du scheißgelbes Ding. Und das ist so die Logik auch von Stefan irgendwie. Das ist wahrscheinlich, Stefan, wenn er von einem Pfeil getroffen werden würde, dann würde er auf diesen Pfeil einschlagen und so, ey, was soll das, du tust mir weh. bin wütend auf dich, dass du mich betäubst. Er ist Pfeil, die eigentliche Quelle ist ihm nicht ganz klar. Und genauso hat er heute auch auf die Pollen eingreifen. Ich bin so gut, das ist die erste Verletzung, die dir einfällt, das mich betrifft. Ich meine, es ist ein Pfeil. Ich glaube, aber wahrscheinlichster sterbe ich durch so einen Buschmensch, der mich in so einem Rohr, so einem Pfeilgiftfroschding. Aber das ist ja noch lustigste Tod, man läuft so mit seinen Freunden ganz so weit und plötzlich aus dem Nix zapp und da ist ein Pfeil im Herz und tot. Einfach. Und niemand weiss, was passiert ist und die Leute müssen nicht einfach begraben. Also man muss sagen, passt das natürlich in dieses nerdy Opfer-Image, was ich mir langsam über Folgen aufgebaut habe, fälschlicherweise mit Marketingteams. Was du mit deinem Sixpack auch nicht mehr lange aufrechterhalten kannst.
Muss ich sagen, ich habe ein riesen Allergie-Problem, ein riesen Pollen-Problem. Manifestierte sich damals im Zeltlager, wir sind fünf Minuten da, ich bin durch ein Roggenfeld gelaufen und den Rest des Feldlagers habe ich in der stabilen Seitenlage, quasi neben dem Lagerfeuer direkt, lag ich. Alle anderen hatten eine tolle Zeit, wow, keine Ahnung, ich weiss nicht mehr, ich war da bewusstlos oder so, drei Tage lang einfach. Es gibt noch ein Bild von mir irgendwo, wo ich auf so einem grossen, diesen grossen Campingstühle, diese unbequemen, wo man, wo ich dann, wo man halt immer so ein Loch drin ist, wo man Bierfleisch reinmachen kann, da wurde ich einfach rauf geparkt, aber auch so lieblos hingelegt, man wurde mir irgendwas um den Kopf gewickelt und so einen Scheiß und leichter rum. Das Bild suche ich euch noch mal raus.
Symbolbild.
Ja, es ist draußen das lauteste Geräusch der Welt. Aber das finde ich so lustig. Stefan, der irgendwie so begegnen sein will, dann so auf Gruppenfotos auch, irgendwie alle so happy und springen die Luft und Piers reing und Stefan so am Rand des Bildes völlig bewusst ist, hängt so in einem Stuhl drin. Und dann auch so ein Fotoalbum, wo bei allen Events irgendwie Paris, Disneyland, alle Happy New Chef haben irgendwie bewusst noch hängt so Sachen. Da kriegt davon immer nie was mit irgendwie, die krassesten Sachen passieren. Ja, das war wirklich, das war Pollen Alert hoch zehn, das war wirklich ganz furchtbar. So Bigfoot irgendwie, Aufnahmen von Bigfoot und Stefan liegt da völlig bewusst. Oh mein Gott, das ist wirklich mein Gott! Das ist nämlich Nessie aus Loch Ness, Wahnsinn, wow! Die krassesten Sachen der Welt, die davon ist einfach immer bewusst. Also einfach, ich glaube, du hattest eine geile Kindheit, hast sie nur einfach nicht mitbekommen. Ich kann mich nicht mehr daran erinnern. Das Geile ist auch, ich habe neulich meinen Impfausweis, als wir nach New York geflogen sind, da habe ich mir meinen Impfausweis und meinen Allergieausweis, Pass, keine Ahnung, Impfpass, mir angeguckt und dann gibt es halt diese Allergie-Sektion, wo einfach alles, ja, okay, schon ausgeprägt, Heuschnupfen und dann Roggen einfach so ein grosses Ausrufezeichen. So ein Totenkopf. Don't never, never touch Roggen. Roggen, was ist so Roggen, was ist so Bullshit? Ich darf es, glaube ich, auch essen, aber ich darf einfach nicht in der Nähe von Roggenfeldern sein.
Ja, so wenn die blühen oder so ein Kram. Aber die haben doch einfach, die machen doch bei so Allergietests, machen die doch so ein grosses Schachbrettmuster mit so einem Kugelschreiber auf deinen Unterarmen, so war das bei mir. Und dann machen die in jedes Quadrat, machen die so eine Probe und dann warst du was anschauen und wenn dann am Ende dann so steht irgendwie fuck you oder so was, dann weißt du, dass du eine Allergie hast und dann weißt du genau, welche Allergie du hast. Da gibt es ja diese von Rian Johnson, dem Regisseur, gibt es einen Film, wo die Prämisse der leidenden Frau ist, dass sie ihr Leben lang, die ganze Kindheit nicht draußen sein durfte, weil beim Allergietest überall es ausgeschlagen ist und die gegen alles Allergische ist, ganz schlimm und deshalb nie raus durfte, es aber herausgestellt hat, dass es nur ein Fehler war, weil sie gegen das Gitter allergisch war. Was, oder gegen dieses ... Wie ein Kugelschreiber. Ja, oder gegen irgend so was, was man dann draufgelegt hat. Ja, das ist die Idee des Films. Ja, dann gehen wir doch einfach direkt nahtlos über einen Filmtalk, oder? Der Filmtalk mit Florentin und ... Marco. Hier ist Marco! Unser Praktikant, hey! Hey Marco, welche Filme hast du diese Woche gesehen? Ich habe gesehen Warcraft, fand ich nicht so gut, mag mir nicht so gut gefallen. Dann war ich in Pulp Fiction. Das finde ich auch mal lustig, einen Filmtalk zu sehen mit jemandem, der keine Ahnung von Filmen hat und die ganze Zeit einfach nur... Oh, ich habe letzte Woche zum ersten Mal Citizen Kane gesehen. Wow, das fand ich ganz schön interessant. Ey Leute, ich hab einen Klassiker gesehen diese Woche, La Vita y Bella, Das Leben ist schön. La Vita y Bella. La Vita y Bella, der jenische Film, und das ist echt ein abgefahrener Film. Er ist auch ein guter Film, aber es ist wirklich ein ... Ein abgefahren guter Film. Vor allem, wenn man ihn nicht kennt. Ich glaube, wenn man wirklich ohne Vorwärts in diesen Film geht, dann hast du echt einen krassen What-the-Fuck-Moment, weil da geht es dann wirklich darum, dass irgendwie so ein Charlie-Chaplin-Figur...
Darf man das Leben ist schön schon spoilern, ist jetzt die Frage.
Ja, du wirst es nicht... Hast du ihn gesehen, kennst du den Film?
Also es geht um so einen Charlie Chaplin-mässigen Tollpatsch so ein bisschen, der so eine Frohnatur, der irgendwie durch die Gegend fährt und dann fährt er mit dem Auto und dann sind die Bremsen kaputt und dann gerät er immer in so Situationen und trifft so eine Frau aus Zufall und verliebt sich da und dann treffen die immer wieder aufeinander und es ist so eine total berührende Geschichte, wie sie dann irgendwie zusammenkommen und so und wie er dann so das perfekte Date plant, wo dann ganz zufällig irgendwie alles perfekt ist und so, wunderbar und dann kommen sie zusammen, schöne Liebesgeschichte, kommen zusammen, Zeitschnitt, so ein Kind, sie haben ein Kind bekommen und BÄM, sie werden in KZ gebracht. Alle drei kommen in ein KZ, ja, BÄM, ab dann einfach alles im KZ. Ab dann der Filmtitel nochmal, aber wenn so ein Nicht-Dingeschrieben ist und das Leben ist nicht so schön. Oder schön in Anführungszeichen einfach. Und einfach nochmal Kapitel zwei. Und ab dann in KZ. Das Leben ist schön. Und es ist tatsächlich ein echt berührender Film, muss man auch ganz ehrlich sagen, weil der Vater, um sein Kind zu beschützen, tut so, als wäre das Ganze nur ein Spiel, dieses KZ.
So ein Spiel, und das müssen sie durchhalten, und wer als letztes durchhält, kriegt einen grossen Preis.
Und es ist alles nur Spiele, die die machen müssen.
Das Leben.
Und so.
Ein sehr grausames Spiel.
Ja, das Spiel ist so, wir werden alle sterben, und wenn wir am Ende noch überleben, der hat gewonnen. Glückwunsch. Genau, aber das ist echt eigentlich sehr berührend, weil er dann auch immer so versucht, die Fassade aufrechtzuerhalten und immer so versucht, zu tun, dann auch andere Häftlinge dann irgendwie auch mitspielen und mit dem Kind dann so, ah, ich hab diese heute nur fünf Punkte bekommen und ihr habt ja schon vierzig Punkte, ihr seid ja total weit vorne und so. Das ist echt sehr berührend eigentlich und das ist echt ein ganz schöner Film. Aber wenn man das echt nicht weiß und man denkt, okay, vor allem das ist so, ich glaube, das ist eine Struktur, die man heute in Filmen nicht mehr so hat, dass Filme so einen harten Bruch in der Mitte haben, dass du hast, erste Hälfte Liebesgeschichte, zweite Hälfte Holocaust. Ich glaube, wenn du heute Liebesgeschichte Holocaust machen würdest, dann würde sich das schon von Anfang an... Aber das ist ja bei Psycho auch so krass eigentlich. Den habe ich auch noch gar nicht so lange her zum ersten Mal gesehen. Der ist ja auch die erste Hälfte ganz normaler Krimi und dann wird er einfach zu so einem Horrorfilm. Das ist ja auch schon ziemlich krass, der Bruch. Aber was ich mir dachte, ich bin mal in Urlaub geflogen, ich weiß nicht so Gran Canaria, so einen typischen Familienurlaub. Dann war es aber so, dass ein sehr trauriger Film lief, ein billig trauriger, und das waren halt nicht damals, wo diese Flieger, wo jeder seinen eigenen Fernseher hatte, sondern alle mussten halt, es in einem Film gucken, der angeboten wurde. Es war halt ein sehr trauriger Film und es haben einfach alle, wirklich, ob jung oder alt, alle haben angefangen zu heulen in dem Film, Stewardessen waren am heulen, alle am heulen, und wenn ich manchmal so am Boden sitze, weil ich die Sonne auf dem Bauch scheinen lasse, schon mit meinem Pinacolada im Garten sitze und dann so ein Flieger vorbei ist,
wie ich sehe. Erstmal am Heulen, alle am Heulen. Und wenn ich manchmal so am Boden sitze, ich weiß nicht, die Sonne auf dem Bauch scheinen lasse, schön mit meinem Pinacola da im Garten sitze und dann in so einem Flieger vorbei sehe, denke ich manchmal so, oh, vielleicht sind die gerade alle am Heulen. Ich finde diese Vorstellung von einem Flieger, der einfach so schön in den Urlaub fliegt, aber einfach so eine krasse, menschliche Leistung, dass ein Flieger durch die Luft schwebt, aber einfach alle da drin am Heulen sind. Das hätten hätten sich die Ride-Brüder auch nie gedacht, dass sie mal was erfinden. Wir unterbrechen Schindlers Liste für eine kurze Ansage. In 15 Minuten erreichen wir Ibiza! Hey Ibiza! Welcome to Ibiza! Voll die Partyzone. Das ist natürlich eine schlechte Auswahl. Es gab ja auch vor, ich fand es sehr lustig, vor einiger Zeit, wir sind ja immer noch in Topical Island, deswegen ist es angebracht. Die ganze Zeit läuft unsere Lustige Karibikmusik. Das ja statt einem Kinderfilm frühmorgens im Kinderprogramm ein Horrorfilm 20 Minuten lang aus Versehen gezeigt wurde. Aber auch mega lang einfach. Weil niemand der Redakteure guckt doch dann wirklich auch ZDF. Wer von den Kinderfilm, Kinderredakteuren guckt denn dann auch wirklich die ganze Zeit Kinderkanal? Kannst ja nicht machen eigentlich. So bekloppt. Und dann irgendwie kamen dann Beschwerden von den Eltern so so, ey hallo, hier wurde schon die dritte Jungfrau zerstückelt, was geht denn hier gerade ab? Zwei sind okay, drei aktiviere ich nicht. Und wir müssen noch irgendwelche Rätsel nebenbei machen, glaube ich, oder so. Und ich glaube, der Kind fährt auf einem Dreirad oder so. Also ganz komisch, aber finde ich auch sehr lustig, irgendwie einfach so aus dem Nichts einfach dann irgendwie Saw oder was sein. Ich finde vor allem diese Kinder, kennst du Blues Clues von diesem seltsamen, dieser seltsame Mensch. Ja, der ist ganz strange, ne? Ja, er ist glaube ich ein Comedian sogar, Englischer. Aber der in dieser grossen Hose und den gestreifen. Aber der immer sagt, ein Hinweis, ein Hinweis, was, er sieht ein Eis, ein Hinweis, ein Hinweis, wo ich mir mal dachte, als Kind wirst du das einfach nicht für bekloppt verkauft eigentlich. Ja. Ich habe Hinweis gesagt, deutlich, wie du ein Eis verstehen konntest, nuschel ich, man wird doch auch so sehr deutlich sprechend erzogen. Man wird gedemütiger, du bist in der Schule schon gemobbt, dann mobbt er noch so ein komischer Typ. Der mobbt dich so ein seltsamer Typ in Korthose und Streifenpullover. Wo du dich natürlich überlegen fühlst, aber der haut auch noch auf dich ein. Was hast du da gesagt, du fettes Stück Scheiße, was hast du? Ein Eis, du willst ein Eis, natürlich willst du da. Ja, stoppst dir schön rein in deine F, du Spacker. Schieb's dir in dein Gesicht, du fettes Stück, fett, fett. Stefan Titzer, du Titzer, Titzer, Mama, ich will das nicht schauen. Ich habe einen Hinweis gesagt. Ey, ich weiß, kennst du Tom Turbo? Vom Namen. Es lief im ORF, deswegen glaube ich, also wir aus Bayern haben ORF immer bekommen und auch angeschaut und so. Das ist so ein Fahrrad, das lebt und wir sind mit so grossen Plastiklippen. Wir haben es bekommen und auch angeschaut. Wir haben den Kürler gesehen und auch angebissen. Wir haben genau das gemacht, was die Produzenten wollten. Wir konnten es anschauen und wir haben es angeschaut. Wir haben nicht gezögert. Gut, das war die Folge 62 des Podcast-Ufos. Wir wünschen euch noch eine schöne Woche. Bis nächste Woche, dann haben wir vielleicht wieder einen Gas-Zuschauer mehr oder weniger, je nachdem, wie wir es sehen.
Vergesst nicht unseren Periscope-Stream, den wir jetzt jede Woche Mittwoch machen. Ich wünsche
viel Spaß bei dem, was ihr macht. Eine gute Woche, ansonsten, bis jetzt. Ciao. Субтитры создавал DimaTorzok